it's great to be joined today by Andrew
Bustamante who is a former covert CIA
officer and also founder of the everyday
espionage training platform Andrew so
great to talk to you I appreciate it
hey my pleasure thank you for having me
David so how do you how did you get into
this type of work I guess initially how
did you get into the CIA and then once
in what sort of path how is the
particular path that one takes
determined Wow it's uh everybody has
their own journey in so for me my
specific journey was actually not
towards CIA at all I was trying to live
out my lifelong dream of becoming a
hippie I was on my way in the middle of
an application process to the Peace
Corps when I got one of those
notifications that the skillsets that I
brought to the table might have utility
in another part of the government when I
got that notification it asked if I
would be willing to consider alternate
options and of course like any 27 year
old at the time I said yeah there's
other options let's do it and that's how
I ended up getting a phone call from an
unknown number that asked me if I would
be interested in coming up to Langley
Virginia to talk about how I might be of
service to the CIA I was coming out of
the Air Force so I had a clearance that
was pretty unique I had background in
nuclear missiles I had in a strategic
language so it made sense to me when I
was asked but it wasn't a direction I
think that I intentionally went and
sought out myself and what was the what
was the strategic language I spoke
Chinese okay yeah I my Chinese is very
old now and anybody who speaks a foreign
language knows that they age over time
you get you lose your fluency the wiring
is always up there to rebuild it but it
does stale so I ended up replacing
Chinese with multiple languages during
my time at the agency in my last
language with the agency was actually
Thai which is also now aged and a little
bit stale but don't tell my tutor can
you talk a little bit about you know I
think that there we've interviewed
former FBI agents including folks like
Mark Ruskin who has done a lot of
undercover work and one of the most
common answers I get when I say what are
the misconceptions that the public has
about the work that you do the most
common one generally speaking is a sort
of very cartoonish view of what it is
you know high-stakes raids constantly
everything involves weapons and much
more resembling a movie than a sort of
day-to-day law enforcement work so can
you talk a little bit about what the
majority of your day to day was yeah
absolutely the I would say the biggest
misconception about intelligence work is
that it's done at the last minute or
it's done off the cuff
really most of our time is actually
spent planning and assessing risk and
mitigating risk finding alternate ways
to get the information that we're trying
to achieve so for any given operation
let's say it's it's a one-day operation
there's going to be months worth of
planning beforehand and that planning
isn't all that different from the kind
of project claim that you see in a
commercial enterprise people get
together and they talk about where
they're going to get the right loan or
who they can trust to be the best
salesperson for something or you know
how to assess advertising versus
marketing costs it's very similar
they're months worth of planning in your
day-to-day life before you actually ever
get on a plane to go execute on a
day-to-day basis how how political are
the operations that you were involved in
and I'll add some context so as you're
probably aware right now the entire
intelligence community has sort of
become the center of very very political
debates related to investigations of the
president former investigations into
Hillary Clinton day-to-day decisions
text messages of Peters struck from the
FBI and how where there is a line
between one's personal politics and
their work within the agency so can you
talk a little bit about how much our
politics present when someone is working
and the types of operations you worked
on that that question is a good question
there's actually I want to paint two
different pictures at the same time yeah
you've got the people who are actually
executing the operation
and then you have the leadership that's
in charge of prioritizing funding and
directing the operation obviously at the
funding level at the level of leadership
it's it is not very it's not super
political but it is political because
what the executive is the one who
dictates intelligence policy the
policymakers your senators your Congress
people etc are the ones that dictate the
collection priorities underneath that
executive agenda so in order to be able
to justify an operation you have to be
in tune with what the executive and the
policy holders are willing to fund
otherwise you're going to propose an
operation and they're going to say
there's no interest in that operation so
no you can't execute it best that's the
more political arm of how intelligence
works the actual boots on the ground the
folks who are really doing the work the
folks who are putting their life on the
line to collect intelligence there's no
politics in what they're doing what
they're doing is what they were told to
do because the intelligence
infrastructure is still a hierarchical
government organization they're doing
what they committed to do to keep
America safe to meet the requirements of
the policymakers above them so one of
the difficult things is when you look at
these conspiracy theories about how
there's all these loose cannons at the
agency it's actually quite the opposite
we are doing exactly what we're told but
maybe what we're being told by the
policy makers to do isn't representative
of the constituencies that they claim to
represent and what are some of those
types of things that that you were told
to do in other words when we say you
worked covertly in the CIA what what
might be some examples of the types of
operations that you were involved in I
have to be really general here to
maintain my lifetime non-disclosure
agreement pleasure so to give some
examples of trade priorities right what
is it that America is willing to debate
or negotiate on in terms of a large
scale trade priority in a foreign nation
there might be something that we are
willing to negotiate about because it's
of interest to policymakers whatever the
trade might be whatever trade item might
be but when we get to the table we might
choose to take a different route because
the policymaker is the one making the
decision about what the negotiation is
or isn't so you'll have an Intel
officer out there collecting the
ground-source truth about whatever that
trade commodity might be or whatever
whatever process goes into making the
commodity if you're talking about child
labor if you're talking about some kind
of abuse of position or unfair trade
practices when the information is shared
with the policymaker the policymaker
still gets to make the decision whether
or not they leverage the information
they were given or if they just choose
to go out on their own with maybe a
source of information from a different
intelligence service like dia or NSA so
is that sort of like collecting a
blackmail file of sorts to apply a
negative term to it but in other words
you're collecting information that if
the circumstances warranted could be
used to gain leverage over a negotiating
partner no I wouldn't compare it to
blackmail because of one very important
reason blackmail is meant to meant to
intentionally force someone's hand
through some negative incentive right
what we are absolutely doing is
collecting information that can be used
for leverage
but that leverage doesn't have to be
negative right it in most cases using
some sort of conspiratorial or some sort
of negative lever is actually a way to
destroy negotiations which is kind of
what we've seen happen with our
government shutdown yeah we don't
destroy negotiations we want to add
positive leverage to give us an
advantage in negotiation what are the
skills that go into the type of work
that you did and this will sort of start
to get us a little bit into the everyday
espionage training platform that you've
developed what what are the the sort of
primary skills and then how do some of
those translate into sort of utility for
the everyday person in their day to day
life yeah there's there's there's a
number of different skills that agency
officers use in the field and also in
the in the work force and as they deal
with other agency officers who are you
know doing the same kind of work and we
have competing priorities the the reason
that I feel like there's value in these
skills in the real world
because much of what an intelligence
officer does in their day-to-day life is
just a different derivative of what
everyday people do but we don't know
that because that's not the picture that
Hollywood paints so hasn't well we have
a concept that we have a proprietary
term but it's a it's a concept that I
tend to reference and I call direct
dialogue it's when you shape a dialogue
between two people because the dialogue
has to have inputs from two people but
you shape the content of that dialogue
with a very specific direct intention at
the end it's not that different from
saying negotiation except that people go
into a negotiation knowing that there's
something they want at the other side
the vast majority of conversation the
mat and the majority of dialogue between
any two people is actually it's the it's
got no direction it has no express
purpose except to just be dialogue when
you learn how the mind works when you go
through Farm training or when you go
through some of the advanced training at
CIA you start to realize that there is
actually a purpose behind every dialogue
we just don't define it before we start
talking hmm direct helps people to
understand you have a purpose there's
something that you want maybe it's not
going to happen in one conversation
maybe it takes 12 conversations but how
do you start strategically laying the
foundation so that you are in control of
the dialogue from beginning to end that
has huge utility if you're talking about
a career choice a promotion or some sort
of big project that you want to take on
it has everything to do with a
relationship building a relationship
whether it's a marriage or a business
partnership or even a relationship with
your kids to have control over the
dialogue itself so that you can build a
very specific outcome that you're
pushing for so I think that one is an
easy one for most people to understand
it relates to sort of conversational
dynamics and and social psychology what
about some that might be less obvious
skills that would translate from
clandestine and covert work to
day-to-day life um so there's a second
example that I don't know if it
qualifies as less obvious but I have
certainly seen it run into significant
roadblocks and that skill is situational
awareness most are aware of the term
situational awareness but I find that
there is a lack of conviction in
understanding how to use and apply
situation situational awareness so just
as a quick example everyday espionage I
build curriculum
I provide spy training courses to people
to teach them these skills in the
context of the real world using the
confines and the definitions that we use
in espionage when I introduced this idea
of situational awareness to specific
leaders in my example Florida Florida
State Schools County Public Schools for
students I explained the situation
awareness could reduce the incident of
the risk of an attack from any kind of
mass shooter any kind of violent act the
kidnapping drug dealers whatever might
be happening on a school ground simple
situational awareness would help resolve
that situational awareness among your
teachers among your staff among your
students when I laid out this very
simple concept and I explained how field
officers are taught situational
awareness because they are independently
responsible for their own safety and
because of that they need to be more
aware of their environment than anybody
else when I explained that to the school
board
I had overwhelming support from police
and fire department representatives and
EMTs and anybody who is familiar with
first responder duties but it landed on
absolute deaf ears with the school board
itself even before we started talking
about how much it would cost to teach
people situational awareness which cost
very low once we started even
entertaining the idea that people had to
take independent responsibility for
their safety the whole conversation
broke down and that same breakdown has
happened on multiple fronts as I've
tried to engage nonprofits as I've tried
to engage for profits there's there's
this cultural tendency in America that
we are supposed to outsource our
security it's somebody else's problem
it's the police department's
responsibility it's the security
department some security forces
responsibilities it's our parents
responsibility as our employers
responsibility to keep us safe
when
that's not a well that I mean I think
that you're right that for some people
there's a very specific explanation that
is aligned with there may be values or
worldview or they would say it's simply
I believe the responsibility falls on
someone else but to take a step back
from that element of it there's also
something maybe a little bit unnatural
about sort of like a persistent
situational awareness I mean most people
I think if they're in a movie theater
for example and they just get immersed
in the movie that they're watching as an
example or you're on a plane and at a
certain point you're you're not
necessarily in that state because you're
just reading a book or looking out the
window or whatever there is something a
little bit unnatural that requires
training about maintaining that kind of
awareness is there not no you're
absolutely correct that that's why I
think it is a valid training opportunity
but along with the training of how to
maintain situation awareness there's
also the training that goes into how
best to utilize it you you can't be in
what we call a yellow state all the time
constantly scanning for risks but what
you can do is know when you need to be
in a yellow state and when it's safe to
be in a green state or a white state a
state of safety it's just like driving a
car you're supposed to be in a yellow
status when you drive windows being
constantly aware but we all know that
more and more people are driving in a
green state or a white state where
they're looking at a phone or they're
there playing with a radio when they
should be paying attention to the
threats around them before we sort of
start winding down I wanted to get your
thoughts on if if you think
forward-looking in the next few years
what would you assess as the biggest
national security risk to the United
States and so all all answers are valid
whether it's something along the lines
of cyber attacks climate change anything
I mean really just based on the work
that you do what are you looking at
right now I'm always watching I'm always
watching technology specifically I'm
watching how people replace daily or
individual actions with Knology social
media I think was a fantastic example
back in the early 2000s it it started to
replace axe
physical social interaction and you
start to see how people replace being in
a actual work environment with working
remotely so the phone and email and and
IMS and text messages replace what was
otherwise actual human collaboration so
I'm always looking towards how
technology is going to impact us and the
reason I find it to be so interesting is
because technology takes gigantic
innovative steps forward and then we as
humans are left trying to catch up
trying to find a use for them so I've
actually commented on anything from
social media to blockchain technology to
to you know future innovations when it
comes to how Wi-Fi or how information
will be communicated in the future
technology is for me both the greatest
opportunity and in many ways the
greatest threat that faces us yeah I and
that could go in a lot of different
directions but it sounds like as a
possibility under that umbrella
cyber warfare is definitely a possible
component at least I don't know if I
would call it cyber warfare and I and I
understand what you're trying to say
you're trying to get me to a specific
threat yes but I want to avoid specific
threats because I'm especially in this
area cyber warfare as an example there's
not many people out there who can engage
in it so what kind of what level of
threat is it really if there aren't many
players that can really leverage that
threat
if someone chose to make a cyber attack
it would be terrifying right it would be
devastating if somebody chose to say
attack infrastructure that would be
devastating but there aren't many
organizations out there there aren't
many players out there that have that
capacity so you've got to remember that
capability is a big piece of what
assesses the threat overall and
presumably since the number of players
with that ability is sort of limited you
would hope that our intelligence
agencies have an awareness of who those
players are absolutely you don't have to
hope my friend your threats are and when
you talk about prioritizing right all
government money has to be prioritized
the priority goes to those that are the
most active most realistic threat which
is why in many case
is when you read headlines about attacks
that have happened successfully it's
been those low priority those unexpected
attacks and going back to my point about
situational awareness if each individual
had a higher level of situational
awareness when those unexpected one-off
attackers attack the the actual audience
that was their present would have likely
had a role in preventing the attack from
happening at all we've been speaking
with Andrew Bustamante former covert CIA
officer and founder of the everyday
espionage training platform Andrew
really great having you on I appreciate
it my pleasure David thank you very much
for having me